are you familiar with Tick Tock yeah
okay thoughts on Tick Tock real quick
so yes it's kind of taking over the
world a little bit
um
so I have made tick tocks yeah the most
viewed piece of content I've ever made
is a tick tock but how many views 35
million views the thing about tech is
it's not like Universal enough to get
like 100 200 million views but that's
still a lot of views for a piece of tech
yeah you know and it was an LG phone
like that's crazy
um but that's tick tock's algorithm at
work is it's willing to surface things
and show people things that just to try
it just to see if they're interested if
it hooks it hooks
but
um they are behind on the monetization
and the Creator Creature Comforts that
YouTube has been so good at for so long
and so YouTube is going to let us
monetize shorts now next year they're
gonna they're showing shorts to people
all the time they've kind of started to
set the debate for full-time
tick-tockers to become YouTubers and why
wouldn't they there's way more money on
YouTube I think I think shorts in the
long run beats out on Tick Tock I think
Tick Tock becomes redundant so I think
they can exist at the same time until
one of them becomes less cool because
right now you open your phone you open
up Tick Tock and you just know what to
expect when you land there YouTube is
like this app with a bunch of stuff and
shorts so if you're in the shorts
experience I think people just
instinctively launch Tick Tock because
that's what they want yeah but yes it is
really easy to just drop right into
shorts and see all the same type of
stuff and get the same dopamine hit and
the same endless scrolling yeah and I
think that's sounds better too like
language plays a part in this a little
bit like it was like uber sounds better
than Lyft right and like let's make some
Tick Tock let's watch some Tick Tock
let's make some shorts
um like what do you reels reels
halfway better than shorts probably sure
but like short I don't I don't love the
name of it you know that being said I
think that YouTube is where everybody
goes I mean that's our big bet it was
your bet you know it's like where
everybody's going for not only content
but also information so while you're
already there you get that dopamine hit
from these tick tocks yep do you do you
feel pressure because you've made you
have I always ask creators about this
you you make longer videos than I make I
mean
think of it think of a special think of
the longest the most creative stuff you
do do you feel pressure because of how
popular short form stuff is to either
adapt or like cut down stuff for shorts
or try shorts because it allows me to
repurpose content interesting so if I
have a five minute joke that can be
two or three one minute tick tocks or
reels or clips now I'm getting to use
every part of the Buffalo yeah you know
so for me it's great and it's also like
I think our whole our whole strategy was
I can hook you with a minute I'm not
hooking you with an hour right like
everybody will give you 60 seconds at a
time they might not give you an hour so
if I get three 60 seconds of your time
maybe you'll tap into the hour that's
fair so I use it as like a feeder system
it's like the top of the funnel if they
like enough shorts they'll watch longer
stuff exactly but there's even a time
for you where you would make short like
you would have like short interactions
and they would be too short to be like a
five minute YouTube video Yeah and you'd
be like oh we just can't put it out it's
not long enough yeah like that was
recent history yeah 90 seconds it would
be a very funny thing but it's like well
nobody's watching a 92nd right yeah we
noticed that like the The Sweet Spot for
the videos if we were putting out like a
joke was like between like three and six
minutes or something like that it's not
the time yeah at the time right so when
we put out something that was maybe like
47 seconds diminishing returns but then
when we were able to throw that [ __ ] up
on Instagram or now shorts yeah yeah
yeah it's kind of the same thing we had
a lot of I make like the average length
of my videos has gone up but it was like
a five minute video and now it's like a
9 10 11 12 minute video and I have lots
of ideas where I'm like this is I have
thoughts on it but it's not a five
minute video that's just a few it's not
enough for a video but I watch a few
shorts I really like your shorts we've
had those are some of the ideas that
we've gone you know what
this is 60 seconds yep and then we can
turn it into a thing that maybe is the
top of the funnel and it's similar
enough to the longer videos that it can
maybe convert still working on that
YouTube's still working on that but I
think that that's another advantage over
Tick Tock where if you do other stuff it
works I I uh whenever I have a guess on
and I'm starting to get into uh you know
trying to understand like who they are
so we can have this conversation the a
podcast listening to you on a podcast is
going to be the most fruitful for me
sure because it's hard to pretend for a
long period of time like everybody can
do 60 seconds where they're like on
script and they get out this version of
themselves that they wish that they were
yeah but an hour two hours you get the
real sense of like who that person is so
that's like where I get sense of person
but I'm always looking at myself like
what am I going to first for a guess and
the first few videos I watched of yours
were shorts and those naturally took me
into watching your long videos or longer
videos I watched a few like reviews but
that wasn't my intention I was gonna
watch you on a pod and the shorts popped
up and then because of the shorts I
watched a long longer video that's the
ideal that's exactly what YouTube tells
us they're going to have happen more
often and I'm hoping it does it tricked
me and I know that that's the stretch
yeah well couldn't YouTube like I agree
that tick tock's benefit is that it's
the second you open the app you're
getting fed content whereas with YouTube
you're getting fed choices and choices
are paralyzing yeah so I wonder if
YouTube could optimize the UI so that as
soon as you open it depending on your
consumption preference it shows you a
short yep or it shows you a long form
MKBHD video but they have they have
started to do that if you notice like in
the feed they'll start playing the video
if you sit on it but the second you open
it okay the second you open the app
right now I think they still they're
probably doing this now is they have uh
like one or two long form thumbnails at
the top and then they'll peek a little
shorts tab right above that and if you
get right into that short it's over
you're in uh I don't think they can open
with the shorts because YouTube's
library is still mostly long form stuff
and that's the bread and butter of
YouTube but they are sneaking shorts in
there it's in the recommended a little
bit yeah it's on the home page like half
a scroll down yeah so it's they're
they're integrating it don't know if
they'll fully dive I think you get
shorts because you actually watch shorts
more yeah and that's why you probably
got shorts of his first because I've
never got recommended interesting yeah I
love shorts yeah I was just scrolling
through and maybe they started to pop up
but the reason why I asked you about
Tick Tock is because I went on a on a
rant on on brilliant idiots to show you
a Charlemagne that God yeah and about
how dangerous it was to have like
another country's Tech influencing us
right and like basically the idea was
you have another country that can gear
the algorithm to reward whatever
Behavior they want and they could reward
behavior that might not be beneficial to
the next generation of Americans or
whatever whatever other country and
that's why it's dangerous and then I
said that in China the algorithm is
different it rewards not dumb dancing
but rewards you know engineering goals
and all these other things now this got
picked up by politicians running for
office it got picked up by State
Department people it got picked up by
all these I have to tell you something I
made this up yeah I just want to come
clean to everybody I need that up
completely I have no proof whatsoever it
just sounded good and I was passionate
and the show is called brilliant idiots
and it sounds like something they would
do because yeah they definitely cut that
yeah I remember I remember people
sending me stuff of the literal
politician going this is how the
algorithm Works in China this is
sex in America and I was like oh boy I
gotta be careful
truth to my absolute [ __ ] okay so I
think what you're observing is true but
the algorithm I would I would step back
because the algorithm from any slash all
of these companies I would always assume
to be geared to either make them as much
money as possible or maximize your time
on the site happiness on the site which
inevitably keeps you coming back and
makes them more money it's always to
keep you on their site one point of
pushback potentially China is everything
serves the government it's not about
capitalistic making as much money as
possible and they also restrict the
access to most of the other internet so
if this is the internet I have why don't
we just funnel them the thing that's
going to make the best Chinese citizens
yes I think if you even though look at
like
Instagram reels YouTube shorts what they
want is you on the site for a long time
scrolling engaging with a lot of stuff
and I think even with bite dance when
they when they make their algorithm as
good as possible it's so good because it
keeps you engaged is the company that
owns that owns Tick Tock and so I think
in different places where people have
different behaviors that algorithm feeds
them different things because they are
responding and engaging with different
things so if those cheesy dances get
engagement in the US then it'll keep
serving them more of that if it doesn't
get engagement somewhere else it's not
like they decided I don't want you to
see these dances no they'll show you the
dances if you click on them but they're
not engaging with them as much and it's
it's whatever they engage with is
Amplified now now what if
getting a reaction and a positive
reaction becomes part of our culture so
seeking that validation of views is more
important than the thing you're doing to
get the views that's very real right so
if that's the case won't people do
whatever that is to do it and can't you
manipulate them based on feeding them I
don't want to say fake views but making
sure that the tick tock is in the search
way more than it needs to be yeah it is
a theoretical thing that they could do
right like if if they decided one day
that their ultimate goal was to ruin
some election as a company for whatever
reason they could
at the expense of the rest of their
engagement and decide to feed certain
people certain things
but I think still like most of these
companies when they're when they're
optimizing trying to make the best
product they're competitive they're
trying to beat the other companies that
they're true is boring they're going to
get off exactly if you start showing
them a bunch of stuff they're not as
interested in or if you're the algorithm
is ruined and I was seeing all these
videos I liked and then suddenly it
changed one day but the others still
seemed pretty good like all this stuff
also factors in and I think that's what
they care about the most I think they
want to be the best Okay so let's assume
they do want to be the best and they are
incredibly competitive and there is
competition out there it's like I could
go on Instagram I could go on Tick Tock
I could go on shorts you have to do you
have to give me what I want ultimately
you have to meet me there all right
is there danger though in not being able
to
curate the algorithm like I'm wondering
if they've seen what's happened in
America and China right you've seen how
powerful these Tech corporations have
gotten and they go we're not allowed
about to let that happen in China That's
why Jack ma disappears for a month
you know what I mean like if they're
seeing the power and influence of
American tech companies yeah
and how like they have to be integrated
in the government but almost like the
government's like please Google please
Facebook right like yeah it's it I think
they there is naturally and there's also
like
um what you were saying before about
like creators
seeing what the algorithm is rewarding
and then making content specifically to
be picked up by the algorithm rather
than just like being creative and if it
works it works I think everyone and
maybe even like in long form stuff this
still applies like what Jimmy's doing
with like retention and like okay what
is the algorithm reward I will create my
craft around maximizing those analytics
like you can do that with shorts and
that changes what shows up on the
platform so that is real that is a real
valid danger uh and you kind of just
have to like watch it play out and and
turn the knobs behind the scenes I don't
know that there's anything we can do
like as a few people isn't that as
people know but I understand why there's
like concern from government yeah I
understand at least let's say it's not
happening and there's nothing nefarious
about it and it's purely like capitalist
competition that's fine but I do
understand why someone government is
like yo hold up hold on you're saying
they can influence what our kids do
we're the only ones supposed to do that
because please believe America is doing
that everywhere else I would imagine
right trying to yeah
yeah no that's real what about like Tick
Tock as a spyware tool like being able
to look at other apps and like other
things that you're doing on your phone
as a way to monitor citizens and things
like that so they're not supposed to be
able to do anything outside of the walls
of their app
they will have you make an account and
maybe if you log into that account in a
browser there's a cookie that can follow
you and all this stuff but like
as far as what putting that app on your
phone can actually give that company
it's it's not supposed to be very much
and companies like apple Google Samsung
that are in charge of like the security
settings on your device are supposed to
have your best interest in mind and make
sure you can't be tracked by apps that
didn't ask to right so you're saying
something interesting a lot
theoretically it's because like I don't
I don't I can't see what they're doing
behind the scenes and inevitably there
are Bad actors and some companies just
thread all out the window and do
terrible things got it but theoretically
yeah they're supposed to have those
those barriers in place and they're
supposed to do it right